one of the pillars or maybe I should say
one of the central practices is the
month of Ramadan uh what is the
importance of this month
um what is the process of it entail also
so Assam has I think it'd be good to
maybe lay this out for people the the
articles of faith in the pillars of
Islam so the articles of Faith are six
articles of faith and this kind of lays
the foundation for the Creed of Islam so
belief in God belief in the Angels
belief in the messages belief in The
Messengers okay belief in the day of
judgment and belief in Divine decree so
these are the six articles of faith
belief in God belief in the Angels
belief in the messages being the
scriptures belief in The Messengers
being the prophets belief in the day of
judgment and belief in Divine decree
that's what you have to believe to be a
Muslim you have to believe in those six
things right and then you go to
the pillars of faith the five pillars of
faith
are sort of or they make up the
structure of those articles of Faith the
practice of the Muslim so
to be a Muslim you testify
that there's only one God worthy of
worship and unconditional obedience and
then you testify that Muhammad is the
final messenger of God
that's the first pillar it's the actual
testimony entering into Islam then it's
the five daily prayers
practicing the five daily prayers at
least as a bare minimum obligation the
mandatory charity which is called the
zakat that Muslims have to give at least
2.5 percent of their retained earnings
uh to specific categories of Charity
then it is the fasting of the month of
Ramadan
the mandatory fasting of the month of
Ramadan and then it's the Hajj if you
can do so the pilgrimage if you can do
so once in your lifetime so those are
the five pillars of Islam so Ramadan
is a month in which Muslims engage in
this incredible spiritual boot camp
now fasting can mean different things to
different people uh when we fast we fast
from before sunrise to sunset for an
entire month and there is no food or
water period
and no intimacy as well so you would
abstain from intimacy with your spouse
as well in that time no food or water no
bread no nothing you don't eat or drink
even if you live in Texas where you get
where you get these long hot days in the
summer and of course Islam is on a lunar
calendar so it moves every every year
about 10 days earlier
during that time you restrict the intake
to the body so that you can focus on the
intake of the Soul
so instead of being focused on
consumption constant consumption you are
consuming words of remembrance words of
prayer you're to be hyper conscious of
not doing anything that would
spiritually validate your fast just as
you would physically so just like you
won't eat or drink you certainly won't
engage in sin though you shouldn't
engage in sins throughout the year but
uh you know you're not going to speak
words of evil you're not going to gossip
or slander you try to fast with your
eyes not look at things that are not
praiseworthy so you try to engage in a
wholesome uh Act of disciplining
yourself with a conscious of
consciousness of God
but then channel that into engaging the
soul instead exercising the soul instead
and what you'll find with Muslims and
this act of God Consciousness where they
reduce the consumption as they become
far more grateful for the blessings of
God because throughout our lives we just
take sips of water we eat what we can we
snack
when you're abstaining from that you
become so much more grateful for that
sip of water so much more grateful for
that bite of food so much more aware of
the one who provided those blessings to
you so much more aware of those that
don't have the same access to those
blessings that you have so you also
develop a sense of empathy for the poor
that don't have access to those
blessings on a regular basis that can't
help but fast
and on top of that again spiritually you
are engaged in extra reading at that
time people are listening to more
lectures people are uh engaged in extra
acts of devotion extracts of Charity
Muslims are most charitable in the month
of Ramadan so you just feel great and
it's hard to explain to someone that
doesn't do it because it sounds like
torture to people right what in the
world are you doing
you know at four o'clock on a hot Texas
day not eating or drinking you're
probably dehydrated and cranky have a
caffeine headache and you probably can't
wait for this month to be over but in
reality you talk to Muslims their
favorite time of the year is Ramadan you
feel amazing you feel absolutely
incredible because you taste a different
type of consumption you feed your soul
for a change and in that process
you connect with God in a way
that you simply could not without the
distractions of the day-to-day
throughout the year
now it's good that it's one one month of
the year because it's it's honestly
physically taxing right so
it gives you a chance to experience it
for that one month but then you're
encouraged to fast a few days of the
year as well outside of the month of
Ramadan to keep that connection
what are the hardest parts that maybe
for people outside of uh uh the Muslim
faith
um
yeah we'll be curious about
well I think the hardest part is is
physically is it physical or is it the
spiritual I mean uh so as Ramadan goes
on
um your acts of worship increase so in
the last 10 nights of Ramadan
um there is an intense
period
of prayer throughout the night so every
night in Ramadan we have something
called the taraweeh prayers the title
prayers are about an hour hour and a
half of prayer outside of the five daily
prayers so the mosques are packed every
night and Ramadan
um the last 10 nights of Ramadan people
will engage in prayer throughout the
entire night so the only sleep that
you're probably getting
is actually a couple of hours in the
morning before you go to work so it's
everything sort of put together the uh
disruption of schedule the disruption of
diet the physically exerting yourself
but
the way you feel
is unmatched I mean you feel
so fulfilled
through that deprivation and it's
actually the point you know it all ties
back together when you talk about even
tests and trials that God does not
deprive us of anything except that he
gives us something greater in return and
you do not deprive yourself of anything
for the sake of God except that he gives
you something greater in return and so
fasting is an exercise in patience that
unlocks an infinite sense of gratitude
and a greater connection to God